Sie interessiert vielleicht noch wie es
domidika heute geht wir waren sie
nämlich begleitet sie dürfte nach einer
langen langen langen Irrfahrt dann auch
wieder nach Hause kehrende natürlich hat
ihr Fall hier bei Bild dann auch
Aufsehen erregt ins ganze Land hinaus
und dann hat sich die Politik auch
eingeschaltet hat etwas zurückgerudert
aber es war mit Sicherheit eine sehr
belastbare Situation belassene Situation
für diese gesamte Familie die da aus
ihrem Haus geschmissen wurde es ist Zeit
ein bisschen gute Laune zu bekommen denn
wir haben hier natürlich in diesem Tisch
über viele Probleme über viele Krisen
gesprochen und ich bin sicher jeder
einzelne von uns hat vielleicht gerade
eine kleine Krise Existenz gefährdend
oder vielleicht auch nur eine
alltagskrise und da ist mir da können
Sie uns helfen in ihrem neuen Buch
nämlich haben sie 111 Hacks aufgeführt
die uns helfen können glücklichen Alltag
zu haben ihr Thema
im Moment erleben wir alle sehr
belastende Situation und dann fragt man
sich natürlich wo ist die Hoffnung und
wie kann ich selber damit besser umgehen
und ich bin davon überzeugt wenn wir den
Fehler machen dass wir in eine
opferfalle hineintreten und sagen ich
kann gar nichts mehr machen alles ist so
grausam dann setzt eine Spirale ein dass
es uns immer schlechter geht und ich
versuche mit meinem Buch Psycho Hacks
für ein glückliches Leben Menschen Mut
zu machen das immer eine Lösung gibt das
ist auch Momente gibt wie man besser mit
Situationen umgehen kann wie man sich
emotional stabilisieren kann dass man
tatsächlich auch in belastenden Zeiten
zuversichtlich nach vorne geht und da
habe ich aus der Verhaltenspsychologie
viele Ideen zusammengeführt also 111
sind im Buch sowas man wie von einem
Buffet sich aussuchen kann in welchem
Stresssituation bin ich gerade
meinetwegen mit der Partnerin weil es
gibt ja nicht nur die großen Krisen auch
die Ehekrise gibt es weiterhin wie kann
ich das lösen um dann gut gelaunt auch
in schweren Zeiten mein und meine Frau
zu stehen sehr gut dann bleiben wir mal
der direkt beim Beziehungsthema wie löst
man das denn geht man sich am besten so
ein bisschen aus dem Weg man hat den
Eindruck bei während corona-zeiten
mussten viele Paare vielleicht enger
zusammenrücken da ist sie ihm liefer wie
also löst man das jetzt auf dass man
wenn man feststellt meine Güte wen habe
ich nagel heiratet gute Entdeckung
tatsächlich ist es so es gibt diesen
alten Spruch in der Psychologie ihr
müsst miteinander reden das würde aber
meistens dazu dass die meisten sich noch
mehr strahlt und danach die Stimmung
noch schlechter ist als vorher und da
gibt es den Psycho Hack die
beziehungskerze das kommt aus dem
asiatischen der kriegen Ehepaare eine
Kerze über uns so Kommunion also große
Kerze geschenkt und da sagt man wenn ihr
ein Problem miteinander habt dann stellt
eine Kerze auf dem Tisch steckt die an
und trefft Euch an dieser Kerze und
redet darüber und die Idee ist extrem
clever weil wir nicht zwischen Tür und
Angel über Probleme reden das ist das
was wir ganz häufig machen und stört was
am Kind oder es gibt irgendeine andere
Situation für versuchen sofort
einzugreifen dann sind wir häufig aber
so emotional überreizt dann ist unser
reptilienhirn am feuern und wir finden
gar keine gute Lösung anstelle von
konstruktiv was zu machen gehen wir in
Vorwürfe wenn man sich aber zu so einem
ehe es kommt auch in Familiengespräch
oder Koalition eigentlich
dass man Mitarbeitergespräche bei
Kerzenschein zu deutlich besseren und zu
zufriedenen Mitarbeitern führt das ist
entstanden als man so Adventskränze auf
dem Tisch hatte man muss nur gucken dass
man im April dann irgendwann
stehen bleiben und hat sich der Rahmen
hilft und es gibt einen ganz
entscheidenden Trick wenn sich einer der
beiden emotional überfordert fühlt weil
meint wegen jemanden der dominantriebner
ist und dann die Partnerin oder der
Partnerin ich komme nicht zu Wort dann
hatte die das richtige Kerze auszupusten
den Raum zu verlassen wieder frische
Luft zu holen zur Ruhe zu kommen ist
aber verpflichtet wieder zurückzukehren
die Kerze anzumachen wieder ins Gespräch
zu kommen und mit dem anderen das Signal
oh vielleicht bin ich gerade drüber
gegangen aber ohne es ist zu vorwürfung
kommt und wir sehen da wo das mit einem
Menschen miteinander machen wird die
Kommunikation besser weil psychologisch
noch was anderes spannendes passiert das
Kerzenlicht wirkt unbewusst triggert es
den Hinweis romantische Abend und in dem
Moment reden Menschen schon mal ganz
anders miteinander als wenn sich
zwischen Tür und Angel im Stress
begegnen und wir wissen wir haben das
häufig in meinen Seminaren eingesetzt
das Paare berichten dass es auf eine
besonders intime Kommunikationsebene
häufig da noch übergeht was beide damit
einander sehr schön versöhnt das heißt
die Kerze kann wirklich helfen besser
miteinander reden für Sie als Biologin
ist das etwas sagen Mensch das klingt
irgendwie ganz gut Reptilien dann hat
mich auch noch mal kurz an sie denken
als ob sie das kennen ja klar in
Stresssituationen dass sozusagen ist es
nicht mehr unsere Großhandel sondern da
sind sie alle haben Mechanismen die
Flucht oder Angriffe eigentlich Trägern
und wo wir dann einfach gar nicht mehr
groß reflektieren was wir tun welche
Folgen das hat
das wird bei Stress aktiviert genau aber
wie man das am besten steuert da sind
sie als Psychologe eher der Fachmann
jetzt haben sie ja schon mal da haben
wir darüber gesprochen das sind ja dann
auch noch mal ganz reale Krisen auch
noch mal in diese Runde zu holen wir
haben über die Drohnen gesprochen die
sie bekommen macht sie das
beispielsweise schlaflos haben sie da
Ängste
vor der Entscheidung des
sonderkreistages im Januar
war ich überlegt hatte gibt es andere
Lösungen und die gab es nicht natürlich
macht das mit dem was wenn man wenn man
darüber nachdenkt man könnte
vergleichbare Fälle diesmal gab in
jüngster Vergangenheit aber ich bin da
ganz froh mut ist dass sie Behörden und
die Sicherheitsbehörden dann Blick drauf
haben und man muss einfach mit
Wassermann Auge voranschreiten und ähm
es gibt immer einzelne die dann was
besser meinen oder sagen Mensch dreht
zurück oder hör auf oder du hast ein
bisschen Versager
die Lösung dessen ist ja nicht der
Landrat der auf dem Stuhl sitzt und auch
die 280 landräter 283 in Deutschland
sondern insgesamt das Problem
das kennen dass man eben nach da liegt
und grübelt entweder hat man
Existenzängste oder man grübelt über
eine Situation eine konkrete nach oder
man sagt sich beispielsweise ich bin
tatsächlich da und da ein Versager oder
ich habe das nicht richtig gemacht wie
durchbricht man das
wir bleiben noch 109 über einer meiner
lieblings Psycho Hacks den habe ich
selber in der großen Lebenskrise für
mich zufällig entdeckt und dann weiter
ausgebaut ist Gründe eine
whatsapp-gruppe mit dir selbst also
WhatsApp dich selbst heißt der Trick
WhatsApp Gruppe mit sich selber ist
schön man sucht jemanden
anderen raus weil es die Schwiegereltern
sind kannst du sehr unterhaltsam
Gesprächen führen und man muss hinter
verraten warum und jedes Mal wenn einem
was gut gelingt Bayern schon mal eine
gute Entscheidung getroffen dann spricht
man sich selber eine Sprachnachricht auf
die man sich selber sendet in diese
Gruppe hinein und das trainiert zum
einen sich selbst wieder zu loben weil
wir Menschen ziehen uns permanent runter
und wir haben wir beschimpfen uns
permanent für Sachen die wir nicht gut
machen und loben uns viel zu selten weil
wir sind Satz
Selbstlob stinkt in uns tragen sich
selber loben hilft schon mal wir lernen
wieder wahrzunehmen was auch in schweren
Zeiten gelingt und wenn es ein ganz
dreckig geht dann nimmt man dieses
Smartphone und hört sich an was man in
den letzten Wochen alles Gutes
hinbekommen hat und das steigert die
selbstwirksamkeitsüberzeugung und wenn
wir von unserer eigenen Wirksamkeit
überzeugt sind sind wir
krisenresistenter und der letzte Vorteil
dabei und das ist erst eine Teilnehmerin
aufgefallen sein tiefenpsychologischer
Effekt ganz häufig klingt unsere Stimme
ähnlich eines unserer Elternteile
und das war tatsächlich hier das klingt
jetzt ein bisschen verrückt aber es war
wirklich eine Frau der Mutter schon
verstorben war die immer eine sehr harte
Person war die der Tochter nie das Lob
gegeben hat und plötzlich diese Frau ist
Jutta hörte sie die Stimme die ihre
Mutter ähnlich klauen und auf
Bewusstsein ist nicht aber das innere
Kind diese unbewusst den hat plötzlich
die sagte Jutta du kennst viel mehr hin
als du selber manchmal von dir denkst du
darfst stolz auf dich sein die sind echt
die Tränen geflossen weil sie nicht
diese Wertschätzung Anerkennung bekommt
nach der ist nach Jahren gesucht hat mit
einem einfachen Heck WhatsApp sich
selbst
vielen herzlichen Dank vielen herzlichen
Dank an diese Runde wir schauen mal
überprüfen noch mal ob es eigentlich
Kerzenschein Beleuchtung für ein Studio
gibt vielleicht sind die Gespräche dann
noch mal ganz andere Adverb weiße Zinsen
sich eine Kerze zu Hause an machen sie
es gemütlich ich freue mich riesig wenn
wir uns morgen Wiedersehen bis dann
wurden sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
für Sie